welcome everybody we are here once again
I I just ate a pair if you can imagine
that I know it sounds really really
crazy but I did I did it I did it I'm
going to try to suffer through what we
have today which is Donald Trump in an
in a roundtable with industry executives
on opening up America now if you were
here yesterday I had to stop short the
stream I essentially had to prematurely
pinch off the stream because I couldn't
take it it was just total disgusting
propaganda I needed we do Trump but he
brought up as political props people
with cognitive disabilities while not
mentioning the fact that we've blown
past the 60,000 person death toll that
Donald Trump was promoting and was
counting on I just couldn't make it
yesterday I couldn't make it and we're
going to try today because there were
actually questions at the end yesterday
and maybe there will be some today none
of them were particularly nasty but
there were questions so we're gonna try
to do it all together today and that is
that is what is upcoming as people come
in let me discuss a few different things
that are going on
first and foremost officially the global
number of coronavirus cases is within
minutes going to hit 3.2 million cases
226 thousand deaths nearly a million
people have recovered from the virus in
the United States the official count has
just surpassed 1.05 million almost 61
thousand deaths and we are seeing
unfortunately we're clearly in a plateau
but it's not a very rapid descent we
have essentially been in a plateau for
25 days at this point we can sort of say
the plateau started on April 4th when it
comes to deaths much less clear an
almost record-breaking number of deaths
yesterday so again I guess the plateaus
sort of started on April 7th with the
deaths but after a couple of better days
back up the verdict is we need more time
and here in Massachusetts
it's stay-at-home extended from May 4th
until May 18th an additional couple of
weeks and we are going to we we are
going to see how that continues we have
very good news
potentially about the vaccine now I
think it's really important to point out
a whole bunch of disclaimers for any of
what's in this New York Times article to
be accurate we need things to go
basically perfectly from now until
September but the idea is that there is
a the Oxford Oxford University I'll just
like give you the minute summary
Oxford University is sort of ahead of
the game on a coronavirus on a coat on a
Tsarskoe v2 vaccine because they've been
working on coronavirus vaccines for a
while they have one that they already
believe to be safe in humans they tested
it on rhesus monkeys and it prevented
six rhesus monkeys who receive the
vaccine from getting the virus after
being exposed the monkeys that didn't
receive the vaccine did contract the
virus next month May they will be doing
a six thousand human trial and if
everything goes ok this could be
available under emergency use a few
million doses likely to healthcare
workers starting in September if
everything goes well now of course a
million different things can happen and
we can talk tomorrow on the program in
more detail about that REM des aveer ok
not hydroxy chloroquine as Donald Trump
likes to say but rim des aveer this is
the drug from Gilead pharmaceuticals
Gilead Sciences this is a drug that's
been around for a little while this is
actually a test with placebo this is
really important a lot of these tests
that are like hey we gave people this
thing and like 60% got better ok well
how many would have gotten better anyway
how many got better
what's the placebo effect etc right very
important hospitalized patients with
advanced COBIT 19 in lung involvement
who received from des aveer recovered
faster than similar patients who
received placebo according to a
preliminary data analysis from a
randomized controlled trial with a
thousand patients very very important
let's listen if we have time I think we
do to a little bit of dr. Anthony foutch
II talking about it a trial that the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases which is the
Institute I direct sponsored called the
adaptive Co virus disease treatment
trial acct one was started in February
21st of this year and it was a
randomized placebo-controlled trial
that's right comparing the Gilead drug
Ram disappear with a placebo it was
highly powered with about a thousand
ninety plus individuals so it is the
first truly high powered randomized
placebo-controlled trial it was an
international trial involving multiple
sites not only in the United States but
in various countries throughout the
world including Germany Denmark Spain
Greece the UK etc the primary endpoint
was the time to recovery namely the
ability to be discharged when you have a
study like this we have a data and
safety monitoring data which looks at
the data and they are independent so
there's no prejudice on the part of the
investigators because they're doing the
trial or the drug is from a certain
company the data and safety monitoring
born on Monday afternoon contacted me on
April 27th first on Friday the week
before and then again on April 27th and
notified the study team namely the
multiple investigators who were doing
the study throughout the world that the
data shows that REM de Sevilla has a
clear-cut significant positive effect in
diminishing the time to recovery this is
really quite important for a number of
reasons and I'll give you the data it's
highly significant if you look at the
time to recovery being shorter in the
REM death severe on it was 11 days
compared to 15 days that's a p-value for
the scientists to a-listening of 0.001
so that's something that although a 31%
improvement doesn't seem like a knock
out hundred percent it is a very
important proof of concept because what
it is proven is that a drug can block
this virus and I'll give you an example
in a moment of why we think so that's
the the gist of it and we'll have more
coverage about that tomorrow now a
question that this study does not answer
is okay the people who got it versus the
placebo recovered 30% faster but can it
help someone who would not recover at
all to survive right so that's another
question and maybe there is something in
the study about it I've not looked at
after the full study yet but that would
be a relevant question in addition to
whether it helps people recover more
quickly then there are questions about
whether it shortens the amount of time
that one is contagious right eliminating
symptoms more quickly is one thing
reducing the time someone is contagious
there's a lot of other questions but
this is a good thing remember I told you
about all of these drugs months ago so
before Trump started promoting hydroxi I
came to you I said we're looking at
chloroquine with or without a z-pack
we're looking at room deser vir we're
looking at the Pahlavi R also known as
EV again we're looking at two HIV drugs
I told you about I don't I don't have
any emotional or financial connection to
any of these but we now have learned
about room des aveer and hopefully there
is something significant about this let
me oh but before I move on just very
very briefly thank you to Kyle Brown
Kyle Brown just got a membership at join
pakman.com I really appreciate that Kyle
and Kyle is new member number one as you
can see today also on Twitch 24 has
subscribed with twitch Prime and says
hey David remember if you have Amazon
Prime it costs you nothing to subscribe
with twitch Prime but we get a few bucks
you pay zero you take it out of Jeff
Bezos pocket and you give it
me can you imagine something better than
that a few super chats coming in Paul
Newman says hey David your girlfriend is
a lucky girl and I bet she disagrees
that's right she wouldn't take this luck
to Vegas let me tell you that for sure
Walker Anderson says you posted a video
on the laughable gang rape charge
against Cavanaugh why haven't you posted
one single video on Tara Reid I've
addressed Tara Reid multiple times and
there will be three two or three more
videos posted about Tara Reid in the
next 48 hours
ken h says the same people protesting
further freedom from stay at home orders
are the same people praising Trump for
ordering people into unsafe workplaces
what are your thoughts you are you are
picking up on just one of the many
double standards and hypocrisy
there yes pare tearin' with a thousand
Swedish kronor super chat I think that's
like a hundred and a hundred dollars 198
dollars maybe thanks pare says so did I
you have my sympathy listen to Trump is
like have a food mixer
Monsieur brain you know what pair I
think you're right I think you're right
Adrien benningfield says David a problem
I am thinking is going to happen is
heatstroke and secondary effects due to
wearing masks during the hottest months
well you know but in in my view for the
most part the masks are for indoors and
most of those indoor public places will
have air-conditioning so hopefully it'll
be okay hopefully they'll be okay nasty
questions says Trump thrives on the
confrontation from nasty questions this
is not an alias says do you think that
perhaps dr. Bergson foutch you were
trying to go to do good doctor bad dr.
Trump would have fired Burks quickly if
she had said anything negative as he is
so sexist I don't know if the behavior
of pouchy and Burks is a sort of
good-cop bad-cop type of thing I'm not
sure about that
Patrik Nielsen says planted any sugar
snaps David ditch the cukes you know I I
have not been able to plant my sugar
snaps yet because I'm still waiting on
the seeds Amazon shipping is
delayed that I've not gotten the seeds
yet but you should see the sprouts I
have going I've got a bunch of herbs for
tomato plants now going and and I have
planted cucumbers we will see if they
sprout but I've got much to plant much
to plant Marcus dower says will we play
bingo tonight probably not this is a
sort of round table type thing it's not
the typical briefing so I don't know
that the bingo format necessarily works
for us today but I'll keep an eye on it
ACEF Barham says hi David how many miles
do you put in running each week uh I I
don't run that much because I genuinely
don't think it's that good for the knees
so I'm I probably run five miles a week
and I'll do like you know a mile and a
half three times a week or something
like that but biking though love biking
um let's see here Tracey Kay says hey
David from Ontario Canada what are your
thoughts about Justin Amash and Jesse
Ventura's decision to join the
presidential race I that is addressed on
today's bonus show so I don't want to do
it here I'm trying to avoid doubling up
on stuff Danny Thompson says now that
meatpacking plants are essentials taking
away the company's liability to
employees ability to sue are we possibly
seeing the nearly forced end of labor
unions and their protections as they are
now yes and we address that on today's
bonus show as well so a lot of these
very important topics we did discuss
today on the bonus show which as a
member or patron you would have direct
perfect access to as I like to say let's
see if c-span is preparing a feed for us
for the top of the hour not clear c-span
is going to be streaming this one we
will see we are standing by waiting for
Fox News as well as the White House feed
for the top of the hour Roundtable okay
let's see a couple of other things that
I wanted to look at with you you may
have heard that Mike Pence went to the
Mayo Clinic where there are coronavirus
patients sick people everyone's wearing
a mask pence though no masks
[Music]
everybody wearing a mask patients
doctors Secret Service nurses in the
background but not pence why not here is
his explanation well let me say as vice
president of the United States
oops oh my god I'm sorry I clicked off
oh boy everything going wrong I'm really
sorry about that hold on a second where
is that here it is let's let's go here
well let me say as vice president in the
United States I'm tested for the corona
virus on a regular basis and everyone
who is around me is tested for the
corona virus
anybody could be asymptomatic or
pre-symptomatic and have acquired the
virus since the last test and when the
CDC issued guidelines about wearing a
mask it was their recognition that
people that may have the corona virus
could prevent the possibility of
conveying the virus to someone else by
wearing a mask and since I don't have
the corona virus I I thought it'd be a
good what he means is he didn't test
positive at the last time that he was
tested ready for me to be here and to be
able to speak to these researchers these
incredible health care personnel and
look them in the eye and look them in
the eye
dispense think that the mask covers your
eyes maybe there's a different type of
white mask that Pence is familiar with
or used to that covers your entire face
if people know what I mean but no the
mask would typically only cover your
mouth and nose and you would be very
well able to look at people right in the
eye so so pens just an absolute total
totally disrespectful you know there are
people whose family members are at the
Mayo Clinic with the virus they can't
even go visit with a mask and Mike Pence
is walking around there with no masks
whatsoever just absolute and completely
disgusting guy
let me say a few twitch thank-yous Ms
toe flies has subscribed cynic says why
are we still watching these at this
point David it's literal [ __ ] show it's
so that we can all be together and so we
can all be together a user named 266 550
has subscribed with Prime and yari 318
has also subscribed with prime also a
huge thank you to Arlene gots Feld who
is new member number two today at join
pakman.com I have a very big show
related announcement to make
we have been man I don't even know what
I want to say right now but we've been
doing a lot of thinking here at the
David Pakman show and we've been
thinking about how to improve and expand
what we are offering and one of the
decisions that is going to be going in
force this weekend over after we finish
the Friday show but before the Monday
show is we are completely restructuring
our are broad not the streams but our
daily show is a radio show in a TV show
we send it out to nearly 200 radio and
TV stations we've realized that the
demand of the audience is going more in
the direction of long-form content it
doesn't really fit on radio or TV into
the one-hour show which sometimes is
only 45 minutes because of commercials
and all of this stuff so we have
communicated to our radio and television
affiliates that the program is going to
be provided in a different format to
them going forward it may or may not be
appropriate for every radio station but
we are going to be extending the daily
show by 10% it's gonna be a 10% longer
show meaning we can devote a little more
time to everything a little longer to
the to an interview longer to stories
longer to analyses longer to whatever it
is that we are doing that is going into
effect starting Monday so next Monday
you we will still have the streams and
there will be 10% more pre-recorded
content every single day and I'd okay
10% oh wow but we about a year ago we
were able to add 10% and a year before
that we were able to add about 10% so it
in Prak
this the broadcast program is constantly
being expanded that starts Monday and
we'll still be here doing doing the
stream something weird is going on with
my hair here which is extremely exciting
and yes the bonus show this does not
take away from the bonus show people who
are members I see are worried are you
not doing the bonus show no we're doing
the bonus show and we're doing the
streams and we're extending the daily
broadcast show by 10% there will be 10%
more memes there will be 10% more
elements there will be 10 everything is
just up 10% right my hair will grow 10%
everything's going 10% up I will sit 10%
higher so I will actually do the show
like this going forever just it just add
10% to everything and what is not go
what you hold on though what is not
going up 10% is the price of membership
right membership prices have not been
increased for 7 years and the best way
to support this stream and the broadcast
show and everything we do is to grab a
membership at join pakman.com I will
only mention it once today I am asking
for your support we've lost about 800
members right from March through now
because of the virus and I I'm with
every single one of those people I
understand what's going on if you're in
a position where you can get a $2.00 a
month membership do it today's a good
day go to join pakman.com the coupon
code 2020 now shops the membership cost
to just 2 bucks a month if you can
prepay for the entire year it's only $1
80 a month $1 80 a month and as always
you can also pledge at patreon.com slash
david pakman show everything counts the
goal is 25 website memberships count
patrons count everything counts because
things are falling off the wall my
commitment is we're not doing layoffs
we're not reducing staff hours we're not
doing any of it I can only you know
we've just got our four employees that's
all I have control over but that's my
commitment and everybody's support makes
that a reality okay I did a very rude
thing which is not turning my phone down
before I started and I am in some
outrageous whatsapp threads that go off
like every 10 seconds so we're gonna
mute
appreciate it very very much okay other
super chats that are coming in let me
get caught up here t love says have you
looked into foul cheese past of stealing
HIV research from another doctor I don't
know a thing about that Remy LeBeau says
any follow-up to your suspicion that
Hillary's endorsement was pre-recorded I
found nothing not pooh-poohing Biden but
I'm concerned loved the show yeah
yesterday right before this the
livestream started of Hillary endorsing
Biden it started and then you could see
someone scrubbing a video timeline and
then it started again like ten minutes
later so to me it seemed as though it
was indeed pre-recorded I don't know
what else to make of it that I don't
know anything else about it I didn't
care enough to look into it further I
guess is my point Paul Newman says
watching Trump is like the moment from
waking up from a nightmare sweating
palpitation and hoping this was only a
bad dream
wake up sadly it is all too real all too
real if you're just joining us there was
a trump roundtable scheduled for the top
of the hour they are ten minutes late we
are live on Twitter twitch YouTube and
Facebook I do want to remind you if you
are watching on twitch tap that follow
button tap that follow button we have
crested over 34,000 twitch followers and
of course as a foregone conclusion if
you're watching on YouTube do me the
personal favor of hitting the subscribe
button and hitting the like button both
are free and take seconds and they
really do help to support the work that
we are doing Paolo Faust says pence
needs to cover with the mask as a means
of prevention of course snake says I
think pence didn't wear a mask for
optics dog whistle to supporters saying
not to trust medical officials or a
general no but it's no big deal message
it's an it's no but here's why pence
didn't wear a mask and we played this
video for you earlier pence went to the
Mayo Clinic didn't wear a mask the Trump
administration has been bragging for two
weeks now that it's almost over
it every day they say it's better it's
better we've almost won and all along
pence has not been seen wearing a mask
if when we've supposedly won Trump shows
up and wears a mask
the optics are oh I guess we haven't
actually won that's why pence didn't
wear a mask at the Mayo Clinic and maybe
vanity I I can't speak for sure about
that pair tearin' says 4 pence even over
that go 4 pence even the KKK mask has
holes for eyes that's a good point
if pence was confused about which masks
do or don't cover the eyes even the KKK
mask doesn't cover the eyes Robert
Archer has upgraded his membership on
YouTube
Brittany Wynne says I'm a federal meat
inspector and at the slaughterhouse
right now and pretty furious about the
executive order big slaughterhouses like
Tyson have already been in trouble for
workers wearing diapers due to lack of
brakes incredible Britney incredible
thanks you're literally at a
slaughterhouse right now that's crazy a
Spencer Hicks has subscribed on YouTube
Baumer Fox says I think we need to just
stop showing Trump these are not funny
anymore
showing Trump's life vests at the
expense of everything else is
irresponsible
well my effort is to fact-check it in
real time and you know we all come
together in a sort of community sense
around these and but yesterday I
couldn't take it yesterday I did have to
bail because it was so disgustingly
toxic um okay Diann albrecht has signed
up post de lluvia m-- has signed up
Brittany Wynne adds I have four plants I
inspect in upstate New York and only one
plant wears masks unbelievable Alex
Koepke says David signed up for the
daily wire a few weeks ago and received
two leftist tears Tumblr's do you want
my extra tumblr I don't know what on
earth you're talking about what is a
leftist tear toe it's tumblr like a like
a glass I don't even know what that
means somebody let me know what that's
about please interpret for me thanks to
Dennis for grabbing a membership on
YouTube JR says you're cutting off your
stream MIDI Vanka yesterday was the most
inspiring display of viewer respect I
have ever seen you are respected
that's right I yesterday I pinched off
the stream in the middle of Ivanka
talking because it was it was too much
it was merely propaganda I also didn't
know there were going to be questions
coming later so I cut the stream and you
know Trump brought up people with with
cognitive delays to use them as props
yesterday it was really sick so we'll
see what we get today we'll see if I'm
able to tolerate it okay Paula Faust has
upgraded her membership Kaylee Belen
Mayer has upgraded her membership on
YouTube and Jerry sis estate sucess
Nikki this super chat has been funded by
the u.s. stimulus thank you very much
thank you very much Jerry I do
appreciate that and we are standing by
for a roundtable scheduled for 15
minutes ago let me say a few thank-yous
to people who have extremely generously
been signing up on my web site let's see
where we can get with our goal of 25
here we go Kayden more is new member
number three today Paul Davis is new
member number four at join pakman.com
Brian Miller you are number five at join
pakman.com Kyle Engel you are new member
number six Benjamin Jones is new member
number seven Mike Holt is new member
number eight at join pakman.com
Nathaniel Spence you are number nine and
John butts is new member number ten
today at join pakman.com thank you so
much I so appreciate that okay
Jake has signed up on YouTube Jared
Johnson says leftist tears tumblr is a
stupid ben shapiro thing okay yeah I
just don't know anything about it lot
Anderson has subscribed at the SOI boy
level jelly Fleck says greetings from
the UK thank you David for your insight
I love the show question can your
president be prosecuted when he's kicked
out of office for crimes against
humanity Trump could be prosecuted for
anything after leaving office I would
not expect it and I would I would really
bet against it quite frankly I just
don't think it's going to have
a couple of twitch thank-yous libor
tribus has subscribed with prime
lone-wolf is a new twitch prime
subscriber Matta dealio has subscribed
was with prime as has lurch a cazzo and
s Smith all new twitch prime subscribers
also nasty questions love it has
subscribed with twitch prime uh thanks
to double Chris for the YouTube
subscription J's review says I've been
watching for a few months have to thank
you David because your videos got me out
of the right wing echo chamber I went to
high school in that's interesting I
wonder I'd be curious where that was
Zak Bushman says given that perception
of the economy determines an incumbent
sorry electability do you think will
recover enough for Trump to have a
chance vs. Biden I I don't know at this
point I I'm not even I just there's no
point in me guessing and pretending to
know I just don't know and only time
will tell
thanks to Wesley Rogers and Camille
Naples here oh she loves you says many
greetings and love from Germany thank
you so much I love the support of the
German people
Amy Guerra says how now we have to
listen to him say REM des avoir yeah
Trump the one time I heard him say room
des aveer he pronounced that rum
reservoir like a reservoir for for rum
it's kind of a weird weird way to
pronounce it by the way I've been going
around for days now saying have sefa
hide or how how was it that Trump
pronounced it I just love this this is
too much it's my let me see if I can
find it here this is my new favorite
thing here it is
Jacobsen ho logic and cephei fevzi
Farhad Dickinson kolodziejczak and
cephei sefa Hyde that's just the best I
don't know why I love that so much but I
do I really really like that one that's
it that's just that's a doozy that's a
really really good one
and it's new cough f Assefa Hyde yeah
you could you could combine both of them
okay JH WH says do you think years of
propaganda about the u.s. being the best
country in the world contributed to the
slow virus response like using our own
tests not the WH O's yes it's a factor
it's a factor the biggest factor is
Trump's delusions of grandeur that's
really the factor tribal sin says main
Tyson plant had eight tests positive
today not good
drive on guard has subscribed at the soy
boy level fashion DIY with Tawana says I
agree with jr. that was the most
disgusting display of his presidency
thus far we applaud you for turning that
crap show off thank you looks like we
are about to get started here oh it's
already starting let's see here here we
go
get ready for propaganda
[Music]
well thank you very much everybody a lot
of progress is being made as you see and
we're reopening our country and it's
very exciting most states are not and it
should have never happened this plague
should never have happened it could have
been stopped but people chose not to
stop it it's a very sad thing for the
world 184 countries at least but it's a
great honor to have you with us friends
of mine who have been truly great
business leaders and our great business
leaders and you're opening up your
company again to if you think about it
thank you
instead of doing a reopening but they're
great companies and they'll do very well
hopefully better than ever before and
that's what we're seeing we're seeing
tremendous pent up demand and we're not
significant so it's wonderful to have
American industry leaders and that's
what you are true leaders to the White
House you've been here before all of you
and we've talked about it in different
times we built the greatest economy in
the history of the world and nobody even
disputes that and one day they walk in
they say sir we're gonna have to close
it up until we get rid of this hidden
enemy this sport this terrible scourge
shared it and that's what we did and we
did the right thing we did an incredible
job we worked with the government's we
work with states all over the country we
had no ventilators are very few from
previous administrations and we we
became the king of ventilators we have
thousands and thousands of ventilators
we're now helping other countries with
ventilators we had old-fashioned tests
that didn't work they'll really obsolete
they didn't work empty cupboard they
were broken and we end up the testing
has been incredible now and to a level
that nobody's seen we're 41st in the
world president moon of South Korea he
said congratulations your testing was
just
nobody's ever seen anything like we're
doing 40 who tested more than all
countries put together not per capita
for millions of tests and the highest
quality test debatable but it's it's
great to be with with you we're joined
by matt mattox of wind resorts Chris
Reynolds of Toyota Chris Necedah of
Hilton Josh Bolten of the Business
Roundtable
Walt Emmer of Waffle House and thanks to
vice president Mike Pence secretary
Steve minuchin and secretary Eugene
Scalia note I just read some Waffle
House's have opened back up and they
have no customers they have like
literally three people went in and as
I've said before it's up to us to reopen
the economy it's not up it's not up to
him it's not up to the governor the more
known I have to say this so strongly we
more in every life tragically lost to
the invisible enemy and we're heartened
that the worst of the pain and suffering
is going to be behind us we think we
really have crossed a big boundary and
much better days are ahead and I often
say I see the light at the end of the
tunnel very strongly this demand is
gonna be incredible I think next year is
going to be an incredible year for our
economy and that is how he's gone from
saying cue three and four will be
incredible to next year will be
incredible
Devin we were talking about that before
you maybe will say something and we're
going to be in a transition quarter next
quarter of the third quarter and I think
we'll do very very nicely there from an
economic standpoint but thanks to the
devotion of the American people the
number of new cases continues to decline
the United States has now conducted
nearly 6 million tests far more than any
other nation as I said somebody happened
of course so many tests and so much has
been learned about what we're fighting
so much winning and if it does rear up a
little bit in the fall or even a lot
we'll be able to put it out we'll put
out the embers it will put out the
flames well two weeks ago we release
guidelines to give States a real strong
indication of what we want and how we
want it done we've really had a good
relation
ship with the states Mike Pence has
worked very very hard with the task
force he's headed the task force so
importantly with a great group of people
and it's been it's just been incredible
what's what's taking place over a very
short it's just been so great I'm
including the gowns and all of the
surgical equipment and the safety
equipment and masks people don't talk
about masks anymore that's the other
thing they're not talking about mess
they were talking about where the masks
because we had a cupboard that was bare
there didn't have a lot of a lot of
equipment or medical supplies in the
cupboard that we inherited now we're
taking in millions and millions of masks
I'll give you a number that you won't
even believe we have an order 500
million masks an order okay and we've
delivered millions and millions and tens
of millions of masks all over so you
don't hear about that anymore either you
don't hear about ventilators you don't
hear about masks and you shouldn't be
hearing about testing but that's the
last thing they can complain about I
guess you know if we do if we do two
million tests they said how come you
didn't do three well we do three and
then they say how come you didn't do for
it I saw you Lyle the second dream for
the media yeah but we've done incredible
with the testing and you'll see over the
next coming weeks Mike you may want to
speak about that a little bit but over
the next coming weeks you'll see some
some astonishing numbers I don't know
that all of that's even necessary you
have some governor's that love the tests
you have others that like doing it a
different way an old-fashioned way with
some testing but we're going maximum
testing we've encouraged the more than
30 states that have taken steps to
resume economic activity already we've
given them tremendous encouragement and
support we're backing them a hundred
percent you know many governors have
called me telling me their plans laying
them out governor of Texas Oklahoma
governor of Arkansas many many governors
I spoke with Governor Cuomo we had a
great talk today on a different subject
but he wants to get open everybody wants
to get up and they want to get open and
would I want to get back to business and
their constituents the citizens of this
country want to get back
and thank you so I just want Americans
are more concerned about making sure we
don't open too soon than they are about
getting back open then you'll introduce
yourself and say a few words to the
media you're covered by your very
serious media out here the audience
can't see it but these are the most
wonderful human beings actually this is
a nice group
I can't imagine we actually have a nice
crew this actually this I think is a
limited hand-picked media group that
would not ask nasty questions that's
what I read that there was just like you
know friendly media today I want to
thank all the distinguished business
leaders who are here in the in the
literally millions of Americans that are
employed at the businesses represented
around this table it's remarkable to
think mr. president before the corona
virus epidemic came ashore we had seen
extraordinary growth in the American
economy yes I'm in a mute pen Spence
continues to just be a horrible horrible
person to listen to so I'll just look at
a couple super chats well pent pens
provides nothing of value nor of
newsworthiness
so we'll check back in momentarily
Dennis says this man never held
accountable for anything I pray he is
held accountable for the additional
deaths one day when they go back and
look at his inaction unknown Prodigy
says is friendly media really media
right what what was that visit or well
who said what is the phrase X isn't
journalism it's just public relations or
something like that things you want
published aren't journalism their public
relations I'm messing up the quote but
there is something about that Lenna
'this is david how do you personally
reconcile his lies
if you mean Trump's I don't I mean I
just he's just a weaponized liar a
parrot's hearin says do you see the
cramming of the table stuff he's bloody
nervous now is the time to go and get
him go journalists go yeah I wouldn't
expect that in this group
Anthony Luhan says anyone else think
there needs to be a not per capita
t-shirt available in the David Pakman
store that was not a bad idea if
somebody wants to develop that with a
transparent background so that we could
print it on t-shirts that's an
interesting idea it's got to have some
kind of clever image remember Paul
Newman says for
decades Europe looked up to the US and
now we are in this position not an easy
spot to fill curious how this will work
out the the u.s. is no longer the leader
under trump on any number of issues
climate change has been the case for a
while diplomacy of course under Trump
and on coronavirus absolutely the same
thing applies mike miller in' says
arizona's cases are still going up 7,200
today with 254 new new cases are not
going down and still going up yeah the
states that have been behind on cases
and that never really closed or have
already reopened they are likely to see
a spike now maybe the warmer weather
will have more of an effect than we
think
arizona's pretty warm a lot of the time
a lot of the state is anyway so we just
don't know
admiral ethos says let's get 225
subscribers so that we can turn this off
yeah while pence continues don't worry
you're not missing anything we're gonna
get right back to this michael taylor is
new member number 11 let's see where we
can get Andrea Hall is new member number
12
Deanna Hovey is new member number 13
Benjamin Kaiser is number 14 today
guy newbie is new member number 15 Ciara
Duffy made a patreon pledge and I'm
gonna count that as number 16 today also
Thorsten Schwab not swab as Trump says
Schwab is new member number 17 today
Judith Conger is new member number 18
today very much appreciate it and it
looks like we are about to go back to
Trump here it is safe and responsible to
do so to partner with governor's across
the country partner with businesses
across the country and open up America
again so Thank You mr. Prem I cannot
just before we go around a Puritan
medical supplies a wonderful company
will produce 40 million additional swabs
per month starting and making it swab
now they've opened up a very big process
and that was funding authorized by the
defense production act so that'll help
the states and again we're there
to help the states a lot of states can
buy their own swabs it's not that big a
deal but we're here to help them we want
them to be successful we had as you know
the governor of Louisiana and today and
we told that story which has been a
really great seller at the governor of
Florida and yesterday and that was a
great story these were just incredible
what's been happening so maybe we'll
start with my left and Chris you want to
take it and tell them about you I know a
lot about your company but maybe pomace
tell the story thank you first off for
inviting me back to the White House I
was thinking today I was here about six
weeks ago the world was a different
place
Trump has no memory we were not at the
beginning but we were in the thick of it
fighting this war and we've come a long
way we've made tremendous progress
thanks to your leadership and the
leadership of the administration there's
represented around this table and
otherwise so thank you for that we you
know we are very supportive as an
industry and certainly as a company on
reopening America we think it's critical
that that happened the guidelines that
you and the administration of outlined
we are incredibly supportive of opening
in a safe and healthy way which which
you and vice president Pence just
described we have been trying at hilton
and as an industry to be part of the
solution throughout so in the middle of
the crux of the crisis when first
responders were unable to get housing
even though our industry and our company
has its share of problems we provided
with American Express 1 million rooms
free of charge to first responders those
rooms are still being provided to first
responders as they fight the war but now
as we think about and I spend my time
predominantly on the reopening of our
business what we realize is that people
do want to get out they want safety they
want to be doing it in a way that is
safe they want to feel good about it but
they want to get out they want to visit
their family their friends their loved
ones they ultimately want to get around
the country and do business again and in
order to do that
they want to feel safe so all the work
that you all are doing is obviously as
ad administration in the states is
critical what we're trying to do in our
part is develop the best health and
hygiene standards that exist so when
they stay in our hotels they feel safe
so what we launched just this week was
in a partnership with Lysol one of the
most respected brands with some of the
best scientists on cleanliness and and
killing one of the most reputable health
organizations in the world we have
developed and are working on the
absolute best protocols when people come
into our hotels the rooms have been
cleaned they've been sealed the public
spaces have cleaning the room feels safe
and secure in that in document so they
can get out and see the people they want
to see and see this great country again
like like they used to we've also been
trying to work guys Hilton's fighting
coronavirus by cleaning their hotels all
right to create a consistent set of
standards so that this isn't just Hilton
the whole industry you know would would
have a set of health and hygiene
standards that would make it would make
people comfortable we will be sharing it
with the administration sharing it with
governor's already to correct try and
create a standard we stand ready as
Hilton and we stand ready as an industry
to help get America open and moving
again
that's great thank you very much great
company and you'll have it up and
running again very soon I know you very
well and you're gonna do a great job
reopening we're reopening Hilton and
we're reopening our nation a lot of
companies are very excited right now
okay Steve do you want to say just a
couple of words about where we are with
the different things was well I think
Thank You mr. president
mr. vice president it's great to see
these companies you chew it's great to
see the reopening I think we're making
an enormous amount of progress yesterday
we met with small businesses so
understand by reopening they mean there
are southern states that are trying to
get restaurants and movie theaters going
and it's not going particularly well as
it shouldn't because it's too early bar
facilities with the Federal Reserve
created liquidity
so that public companies could access
the capital markets and not need to come
to the governments for support thank you
thank you very much
please I'm doing great Thank You mr.
president I'm Walt Amer with Waffle
House in Atlanta Georgia here we go it
is a it's an honor to be here today
thank you for including me a probably a
well dressed cook and dishwasher I don't
know about big companies but but we're
happy to be included and thank you too
mr. vice president for for all of your
support I am here representing our
industry I believe and in large part the
independent restaurant companies of
America that oh I thought you meant the
waffle and that are out here that have
helped create the fabric of our country
with the restaurants that they've put in
our communities and the connections they
have the communities and and we in a
small way feel like we are a part of
that we did have we did have the
opportunity this week in the state of
Georgia and the state of Tennessee to
open up some of our dining rooms to just
read about how Tynan customers again and
it was very welcomed by our people it
was welcomed by our customers
our customers are ready to see some sign
of progress that we are beginning to
move forward we've done it in a safe way
I've never been in a walk we have
followed all of the guidelines your
guidelines the CDC guidelines but what
we believe we when we started out in
this journey we said we really have
several goals and the first goal was we
wanted it to be a safe environment for
our customers and for our associates and
our second goal was to create financial
safety for our workforce and I wanted to
thank you personally for on behalf of
our workforce for all of the stimulus
funds that have gone directly to the
workforce of America it is making a
difference it has made a difference is
keeping the economic engine turning so
ever so slowly right now but it is
helping keep people put the qr-code here
took me to a thing to donate to Trump
should I be worried about that so I
thank you for that
as we got into this we we felt like we
needed to make a lot of adjustments
coming in one of the great things about
a restaurant and the entire restaurant
community the restaurants are the second
largest private employer in the country
and there is a million restaurants out
there and there'll be no other industry
has been hit as hard from a revenue
standpoint or a layoffs and furloughs
standpoint but restaurants if you think
about everyone what's number one health
health care is my understanding yeah
private employers I assume you guys are
number one overall but so you know
restaurants have a unique opportunity to
help lead us out of this and and the
reason for that in my opinion is is that
we have been practicing safe food
handling for see I'm mixed on that I I
valued of course the importance of
restaurants and in the economy and I
love restaurants I've been supporting
restaurants here in the Boston area but
I wonder if places where you can
reasonably be with a mask need to come
first in the sense that you can't eat
with a mask on basically turned our
restaurants into the ability pretty much
at half capacity to to see yes in our
restaurant and it's given us an
opportunity to get the wheels of the
economy our economy our engine turning a
little bit because the next thing we
want to make sure is we protect the jobs
for the people that work for us and
people in our industries so we're very
appreciative I did want to say that ever
since my daughter was young she
everytime she saw the WH on the TV
screen she thought that that stood for
Waffle House so I don't know if you have
the trademark for the WH or we do but we
could probably work something out for my
whi for you this one was here first
we might have to talk then so but thank
you for including us and on behalf of
all the restaurant operators out there
in the country we appreciate this
opportunity to begin the journey to move
forward and thank you very much Walt we
appreciate it Chris Reynolds Chris of
Toyota Oh cuz mr. president thank you
first for inviting us thank you mr. vice
president and giving us an opportunity
to share how Toyota is working within
the
automotive industry to return to work
safely to reopen America safely we
announced on March 18 that we were
suspending production due to the awful
scourge of the coronavirus our people
bomb on March 19 we started to plan to
reopen we started right away and just to
give you some quick background on Toyota
we've been here in the US for over 60
years 1,500 dealers 1.2 million dollar
1.2 million units of cars and trucks
manufactured last year four hundred and
seventy five thousand people employed
including a great number in the state of
Indiana from where our vice-president is
from going to the next slide we with
that as background really are trying to
apply three fundamental principles to
how we're going to return to work
principle number one is we need to stay
connected with our team members so every
week we conduct phone surveys with all
32,000 of our factory workers asking
them how are they feeling what's their
health what's their family's well-being
what's their confidence level in
returning to work and we also preview
with them all of the new safety
protocols and processes that we're going
to put in place we share pictures of the
reconfigured factory workplace so they
can have confidence that we're doing
everything possible mr. president to
keep them healthy safe and productive
the second principle that we follow is
that we've prepared our plants and
facilities for safe and healthy working
so like many here we're engaging in
marked off areas that require social
distancing the provision of masks and
face shields where appropriate daily
temperature screening as well as a daily
app based questionnaire that before you
come into work asks you how are you
feeling today do you have any symptoms
so that we can try and manage and
contain the virus and we're using best
practices not only from your own Center
for Disease Control mr. president but
also from around the world to try and
increase the safety and health of our
team members as they produce and then
the third principle loo here we're not
date driven we're data driven so our
current plan is to open on May 11 it'll
be a slow gradual opening of our plants
around the country but we're flexible
every plant will be different we'll have
staggered shifts we'll do many other
things to come
apply with the Centers for Disease
Control guidelines and our goal is to
prioritize team member and health
mr. president one final point we all
know that our team members live in
communities it's not just the workforce
that they're in they're in communities
so what Toyota has done as its tried to
support the communities in which our
team members live including
manufacturing half-a-million face
shields you guys think that Trump
realizes in a setting like this that
everybody around him from pence to all
the CEOs to like everybody is much more
able to express themselves verbally than
Trump is I don't know if Trump even
realizes that a community service
announcement aimed at those communities
of color that have been particularly
impacted by the lethal nature of this
virus this announcement includes
celebrities encouraging everyone to
engage in safe practices promoted by the
Centers for Disease Control so we think
it's a holistic process we think it's
also a process that requires commitment
and thank you for the commitment that
your administration has demonstrated
we're going to get through this as a
family mr. president thank you so Chris
what's Toyota doing in Japan are they
open are they semi open what's happening
in Japan mr. president in Japan the
situation varies Prefecture by
Prefecture it depends on the plant some
facilities are operating some are not
and that's really a function of both the
the situation on the ground and a given
Prefecture like our state or it's a
function of demand so it varies sir
great job you can have a great Olympics
next year too by the way thank you mr.
president really great Olympics thank
you very much matt mattox please Wynn
Wynn Resorts is thank you mr. president
first I'd like to echo what you're
saying about testing and testing
capacity we have seen a real expansion
in testing capacity in Las Vegas so much
so that our University Hospital is going
from a couple hundred tests today to
10,000 tests a day they don't have
enough people to test so I signed a deal
with them to allow all Wynn employees to
get tests anytime for free and they're
going to set up on-site testing so
that's moving forward we also during
this time too
sited to pay all 15,000 of our employees
from housekeepers to head of sales and
we did that because I thought that could
help accelerate I have some interesting
stories about run-ins with Steve Wynn
when I've been I've stayed at the Wynn
when many times because I go once a year
for a conference and I've got some Steve
Wynn stories for some de-tag tracing
ability on us for our state to get that
moving and we've published a 23 page
plan for the whole world to see ten days
ago that lays out exactly what we think
a strip opening would look like we have
thermal cameras at our entrances we have
company supplied PPE we have just about
every UV technology that you can think
of for disinfectant so we're ready and
I'm encouraging our state that we need
to begin a phased approach and and get
back to business
so Matt when do you think the Las Vegas
Strip will be open again any idea so the
plan that I put forward to the state is
this week let's start phase one Golf
Course tennis courts small restaurant
small retails nail salons etc with
social distancing in place judge the
benchmarks that we've prepared we
prepared three benchmarks based on
disease growth ICU capacity and testing
positivity rate we're gonna have them
out there public every day if we're
inside those benchmarks in three weeks
then on Memorial Day I would hope that
we're open and you have a lot of excess
testing capacity that's great we do
others have said that too we do raaagh
Santa said it yes so all 12,000 of our
employees in Las Vegas can now go get a
test that's fantastic thank you very
much great job set low to all of my
friends I will I will of course
Josh Bolten please Josh business
roundtable missus and does a great job
at the Business Roundtable well thank
you Jewish thank you mister president
thanks for this opportunity
I'm Josh Bolten I'm CEO of the Business
Roundtable and organization of nearly
200 of America's leading CEOs I'd love
to hear from a doctor in million people
every sector of the economy is
represented in our organization so we
have an
opportunity to get a view of the big
picture and mr. president we we don't
need to tell you that right now the big
picture is very challenging we were
facing the largest economic crisis in
certainly an hour in our lifetimes and
and all of our members are keenly aware
of that we think now is the moment that
it's critical that the countries start
getting back to business as rapidly as
possible not just for the health of the
economy but for the health and
well-being of all of our citizens in our
country successful reopening will depend
as as the the other panelists have said
on a lot of different elements and Eliot
may I'd like to highlight three top of
the list is safety first Business
Roundtable companies are all uniformly
committed above all to protecting the
lives and the well-being of their
employees and their customers and that
means following sound public health
guidance like the one like the guidance
that has issued here from from the very
capable people on your team oh boy at
Business Roundtable all of our members
either already have in place or are
formulating careful plans for
responsibly transitioning back to work
like the plans we've we've heard about
just now this afternoon they're devising
new measures around things that there
will be questions asked when these guys
are done and there have been all guys so
far who thinks there will not I'm
curious to see what people think also
well at least there was one non-white
guy all seem to be excellent plans which
takes me to my second point which is
consistent guidelines no matter how good
every company's transition plan is and
we've heard a lot of good ones here this
afternoon public confidence will be
undermined and the speed of the
reopening will be dramatically slowed if
we're all doing different things and
that's why the Business Roundtable has
called for clear science-based guidance
from the federal and state governments
on appropriate safety measures in
multiple workplace and commercial
settings at different stages in the
the disease the White House Guidelines
mr. president that you highlighted in
your first slide the ones that came out
two weeks ago are an excellent start in
identifying a common set of phases for
dealing with reopening and a number of
states are off to really good start in
identifying recommended safety measures
in each of various different settings
now we think since we are now on the
cusp of many places being ready to
reopen more fully we think more specific
guidance is needed and so on Friday we
sent to the vice president and to all
the governor's a set of recommendations
on the kinds of consistent guidance our
businesses feel is necessary for the
safest and fastest reopening and we're
grateful for the chance to engage with
the vice president's team and all of
your task force on those issues and I
should say mr. vice president that
everybody in your administration despite
heavy burdens on them has been very
receptive to taking advice from the
business community and we're very
grateful for that final point ample
testing and monitoring the only thing
worse than unnecessarily slow recovery
is a reversed recovery what a PowerPoint
I mean really how what what amazing
thought must have gone into this it's
real truly stunning advice identifying
rapidly and identifying rapidly and
isolating new kovat cases and carefully
tracking the spread of the disease as I
know your team is working very hard on
the robust testing and other forms of
monitoring are the keys to the vigilance
and they'll also teach us what's working
and what's not working and allow us to
make adjustments it'll take a while for
our economy to return to normal but the
traditional American virtues of
vigilance adaptation and innovation
we're confident will see us through and
get
and get us to the other side of this
crisis as safely and rapidly as possible
Thank You mr. president for thank you
very much Josh there's great numbers
when you look at the stock market today
the enthusiasm is great it's up for
substantially as you know and I think
people are seeing a very big year coming
up next year and I think they're seeing
a very big fourth quarter Larry would
you like to say Larry Kudlow we've cut
Lowe's drunk today just a few words
thanks to everybody mr. president mr.
vice president and all the business
folks and my friends Dave munition this
is a tough one
I've been around a while this is a tough
one and the contraction is gonna go on
for a bit but I like what I hear around
the table and I agree with the president
we will see a growing recovering economy
by summertime and the back ends of the
year and it's gonna extend into 2021
that's what I think's got to happen and
I think the stock market is signaling
some of that I wanted to buck it over to
my dear friend and colleague Kevin
Hassett he he gave it to me over in the
Oval yesterday I want it today but I
appreciate it mr. president thank you
sir kind of like all bent over Thank You
Larry and mr. president mr. vice
president I think when I first came back
back in early March that it was clear
that you had a first objective with
respect to the economy of building a
bridge to the next Shore the other shore
when we could restart the economy and it
was really massive fiscal action that
made it so that a day like today could
be possible whereas you look around
there are all these businesses that have
the wherewithal to start up and it's
because they've stayed connected to
their employees the checks that we've
mailed to citizens means that they're
going to be demand for their products
and so the the big negative numbers that
we're going to be seeing over the next
few months don't necessarily mean what
they would have meant absent all those
policies and so I
that we all have a great deal of
optimism about how quickly the economy
can come back and it's precisely because
of what we see in the room today that
people are have come up with plans based
on the guidance that your task force mr.
vice president have given then make it
so that they can operate safely and
they're gradually across the country
opening up and getting back to work and
they're able to do so because of the
Lifeline that you mr. president through
them with all the first three phases of
fiscal policy thank you and it's great
to have you back too
very talented guy at least he made a lot
of good predictions your predictions all
turned out between you and Larry that's
a it's a tremendous team thank you both
very much you about a gene secretary of
a very important thing called labor
that's more important than labor well it
is so empresa de I was pleased to be
able to tell you earlier today that as
of yesterday all 50 states in the
District of Columbia are now offering
the additional $600 and unemployment
insurance that was part of the cares Act
that you signed last month this was an
additional benefit on top of what the
states we're already making available in
unemployment and one important part of
your program to support workers during
this difficult time
as you know that the states have had
some challenges with their computer
systems we've been working with them
this is not declaring victory on all
aspects of delivering those unemployment
benefits but it is a milestone I wanted
to note I would have been very pleased
to hear the discussion among this group
about all the steps that companies are
taking to keep their workers safe this
is unique to the United States in the
sense that you know when you look at the
press conferences in other countries you
you know you've got somebody like this
guy Secretary of Labor but you don't
just have CEOs come talk about how hey
we're cleaning hotel rooms we're doing
it we're doing it guys everything's
great like it you you know you have
actual medical experts Public Health
people it's it we have these blinders on
where some people might think this is
normal but this is very much not normal
an employee's know as well and and and
we'll continue to do that
we're also receiving complaints from
workers who worried about safe work
conditions or that they might have
experienced some adverse action for
raising safety concerns and and we'll
look into those and will we have the
tools that we need from an enforcement
perspective if workers rights aren't
respected but I'm so heartened to hear
the steps that businesses want to take
and are taking to support their workers
just just a last observation mr.
president as you and the vice president
said just just weeks ago we are enjoying
such an extraordinary economy and and
and there were reasons for that there
were policies that you put in place
lower taxes deregulation that were vital
to what we enjoyed before right now
we're in a period of very important
government intervention we need that but
as we look forward to the department I
think it will be important remember as
well the limits of government and that
the single best thing for workers is a
vibrant economy and that often comes
from allowing free markets and free
people to go about their business we'll
keep that in mind - thank you okay any
questions for our panelists oh boy this
could be a question for for any of the
business leaders but there are polls
that show that Americans say the vast
majority of Americans say that once
they're allowed to go back to
restaurants hotels places like that but
they won't because they don't feel safe
so do you are you worried that until
there is a vaccine people really won't
come back to certain classes of course
we worry about it and we see some of the
same polling and we're talking to our
customers by the tens of millions
hundreds of millions last year we served
a hundred and eighty million people so
we have a pretty pretty big an extensive
customer base what what we're hearing
from our customers is that they're
desperate to get back out and and move
around and see their country again and
see their friends again they obviously
want to do it in a safe and healthy way
and so I think they're looking our
customers are saying they're looking for
for the government both state and
federal government to focus on testing
so that they understand you
what real mortality rates are as work
has been done with the Stanford test and
the you know the the data in Norway and
other data points that are coming out as
the administration and States do more
and more testing I think our customers
what I'm hearing from our customers
they're starting to understand while
every life is precious that the reality
of the ultimate mortality rates here is
probably much much lower than had been
estimated and it's not what the polling
suggests people are thinking but they
have great risk and those people should
be protected but if they're not
they'e probably are at a very low risk
they're then looking for which is why we
launched this week clean stay and while
we're working with our industry they
want to know that people are being
responsible right they want to know that
that we are doing the testing the the
the social distancing that we are using
protocols and PPE in protecting our
employees so that they can protect
customers that we're being very
thoughtful and sensible that when they
do come and stay with us or they enter
into a restaurant where we've always had
good hygiene as you heard earlier we we
are you know our people are trained to
have good hygiene but we up our game so
so that when they're with us
they feel safe so I think it's a
combination of those things that are
happening of probably understanding the
real risk that they have and then
mitigating that risk even further by the
specific actions that we all take in our
places of work with our team members and
and thus ultimately with our customers
well I haven't seen that because I will
tell you to me I think there's a
tremendous pent up demand for people I
see it in Texas where they have lines
going into stores he can keep repeatable
restaurants I guess opened and there
they literally have they have long lines
I think there's a tremendous pent-up
demand I mean people are lining up to
get groceries but I don't know about the
restaurant stuff he's talking about I'd
like to get out as much as I love this
is the most beautiful house in the world
in my opinion but I think there's just a
great demand to get out and
you know get our country going again and
that includes going to restaurants and
hotels and I think you're gonna find
Chris that you're gonna have to a lot of
business that you're not even thinking
about I'm seeing it I feel it and I've
felt a lot of things over the years
including gee I think I can win for
president you know and frankly I really
feel that next year's gonna be a very
good year economically we're gonna be
back in business so we'll have to see I
mean only time will tell but there's a
lot of good feelings and a lot of good
decisions have been made by a lot of
very talented people so I'm feeling very
much that it's gonna be very successful
be mr. president do you want the FDA to
issue an emergency youth Austin
emergency use authorization forum des
appear well it's a big it's a big thing
what happened just recently where they
came up with something that has a very
substantial percentage you know it's a
building block Tony said today I thought
house God will express any time he sucks
medical lingo it means it's a very
substantial chunk of a step and that's a
building block to the ultimate step it's
a big building block when you hear I
guess 31 percent so it was very good
yeah I want them to go as quickly as
they can
Stephen on dr. Hahn has been incredible
at the FDA he's getting things done in
record time there's never been anything
like it and you know we want it we want
everything to be safe but it had it got
into there to see very quick approvals
especially with things at work
mr. president um mr. Baldwin and others
suggested that they'd like to see
federal guidelines for some of these
companies explicit federal guidelines
listing these company and some factories
opening back up so far you've given a
lot of discretion to company in some
states but is that somewhere where you'd
be willing to step in and do more well
we will step in if we see something
wrong we have given discretion to the
governor's that become very well
acquainted with the governor's you have
some very talented governors frankly and
probably some that are a little bit less
talented that's okay but it's a very
talented group of people and they're
working with us we're helping them
whether it's ventilators or swabs that
they can't get we're there and we've
taken in billions and billions of
dollars worth of equipment and
distributed to the states and you know
you you've heard the calls and we have
no problems we're doing really well and
we're backing them up but we want the
governor's to call those shots if we see
something that we don't like or that's
bad or that's unsafe we'll stop it
immediately okay Mike the new normal
three years from now say restaurant
workers hotel workers might they be
required to wear masks that sort of
thing what would being what it was three
months ago I think we want to go back to
where it was I've been when I look at a
baseball game I want to see people right
next to each other I don't want to see
four seats in between every person so
those all would call it watching a game
you can tell Trump doesn't like sports
it's a original size no I want to see
the NFL with a packed house I don't want
to see NFL with three seats in between
people no I want to I want to go back to
where it was that's what we're going to
be look this thing will pass and when it
passes that'll be a great achievement
and we we've done a very good job it's
far too many people needlessly because
it could have been stopped at the point
of origin and somehow we weren't helped
by whether it's World Health
Organization or China whoever
they didn't do what should have been
done down sale actually drop the whole
world it's a very sad thing it was a
very very sad event to war against the
invisible enemy and and we're now on the
other side and we're I think what I want
to see is I want to see where it was and
I think we have a chance have an
incredible year next year now not if
somebody's going to come in like our
opponents and raise taxes all over the
place they want to raise taxes that's
that will kill something very fast we
have something that's very special
we built the greatest economy in the
world and I want to get that back as
soon as possible I think we can start
getting it back very very quickly look
at the stock market today when it has
that kind of Kevin and Larry what it has
I think that if Trump doesn't get a
second term Trump will not oversee
actually getting back to where we were I
just I just don't see it happening
if between now and January it's almost a
record and this is in the midst of
something now we're not in the midst
they feel we're at the other side of it
or you wouldn't be seeing numbers like
this but so we're at 24,000 maybe even a
little above 24,000 and we were at
29,000 we never broke 30 on the Dow so
that's tremendous but what it really
does you have a lot of very smart people
that means that they're looking to the
future number one and I look at it as
jobs I also look at it as sort of
guidance it's a guidance in a sense it's
the stock market who would think you
could have a stock market at 24,000
after we've gone through the worst
pandemic since 1917 that's over a
hundred years you know is the worst
since 1917 so I think that's a great
indicator there's a lot of very smart
people that understand that world very
well and they have a lot of confidence
in it and that's some of the companies
that we hear public companies but it
means jobs
it also means not only guidance it means
some really some people and I know some
great investors people really have a lot
of confidence in what's going forward
and that's what I see and that's where I
want it to be okay
it's
are you open to making a deal with the
postal service that would allow it to
borrow from Treasury without raising its
shipping rates it's a package we have to
reduce the rates on packages because
they're losing a fortune on packages
they're losing anywhere from $2 to 3 or
4 dollars a package every time they
deliver so it's not fair and it's not
fair to the people that work at the
Postal Service you have some of these
companies the internet retail you look
at that and they drop millions of
packages or the post office the post
office delivers a package and every time
they look they deliver a package they
lose from 2 to 5 dollars a package and
what kind of a business is that and you
could never replicate the post office
the post office is massive but they've
got places in little sections of our
country that no company could ever go to
it took hundreds of years to build the
post office and when you look at the
size of it and you compare it to
companies it's much bigger than
companies I mean much much bigger
there's no company that's the size of
that so we know we want to stabilize the
post office and the way you do that is
these companies are going to have to pay
more not the people we're not looking
for the people or the companies are
going to have to pay a percentage of
that that lost you can't do that
government shouldn't have to do it I
think the post office could wouldn't it
be great if I could after so many
decades break even but we're making a
lot of people rich and a lot of
companies rich by subsidizing these
companies on top of that they don't pay
the same taxes as a retail store it's
very unfair to the retailer's you look
at these stores the retail stores are
being just clobbered and there are so
many disadvantages but no when we
deliver a package at the post office
every package it delivers they lose a
lot of money and that's not fair those
companies should pay for it Steve
a president over a year ago asked us to
chair a postal task force to look at
restructuring a year ago we didn't have
any Board of Governors we now have a
Board of Governors that's overseeing it
they're conducting a search we look
forward to here okay so three and a half
years into his term we now have people
who will oversee starting the project
got it okay good
opportunity and we're protecting our
post office by the way and we always
will but we want our post office to be
successful we don't want it to be a
laughing stock and a stupidly run
organization the way it's been for so
many decades now it's ridiculous and
then we make other people rich who make
other people rich because we're willing
to deliver packages at a fraction of the
cost what's wrong this guy other people
gain by it and by the way and you're
hurting a lot of other people because
you're hurting retailers you look at
stores where the stores are they have to
pay rent and taxes and all sorts of
things realizing he's just repeating the
same thing now we're on to the third
time he's repeating the same thing ever
taxpayers that we want to take care of
very very importantly the people that
work at the post office yes please mr.
president if there is another round of
aid for the states in communities are
you going to try to restrict that aid
from going to sanctuary cities and
states I don't think you should have
sanctuary cities if they get that kind
of aid you know if you're gonna get aid
cities and states for the kind of
numbers it's arguable from what I've
read I don't think you should have
sanctuary cities and by the way the
people that have sanctuary cities they
don't like it I think politicians like
it a lot more I go to California I go to
lots of different places and I have
people with a very liberal bent saying
they don't like sanctuary cities they
don't want criminals to be in sanctuary
they want they want they want security
they want safety and you know they want
borders too they don't want people
pouring across into our country and you
know I was there a long time ago the
wall is really an answer but if he tried
to do it it would it would not be
constitutional
based on analyses I've read there's all
of that hundred and seventy-five miles
nobody comes through nobody even comes
close to coming through unless you have
a climb Mount Everest but even they
don't it's not even easy for them Josh
so it's it's been good but we let very
important for you we want our farmers to
be able to get the help and we work it
so it's actually easier for them to get
in you know they've been taking some
people that they've had for years and
years that come with the crops and
everything else and you know that come
with the crop really have been great for
the farmers and we want that to continue
and actually continue at an easier pace
we're working it so it comes in so so
that kind of help can come in even
easier which I think you have to tell
you people explicitly what you seek to
prevent the next round of aid from going
to sanctuary states and cities well
number one we shouldn't have to pay
anything anyway because all they do is
make it very hard for law enforcement so
that's the picture I don't see no answer
helping cities and states if they're
going to be sanctuary because all
sanctuary means to me is its protecting
a lot of criminals and and others many
people but they are there are criminals
and you know you write about it all the
time I see stories every day where
somebody's being totally protected ice
can't get to law enforcement can't get
to them you look at law enforcement law
enforcement hate sanctuary cities we
want a safe country we don't want people
that are sills and governments from
other countries in many cases protected
and you can't get to me that was
supposed to make massive payments to
those states to bail out what they've
done wrong over a twenty five year
period so we'll see that'll be a subject
that will be discussed certainly
sanctuary cities I think maybe was
brought up yesterday and ice made the
statement of people were surprised to
hear it but they shouldn't be surprised
okay thank you president what would you
like the country to fully be reopened to
the way it was before
well we talked about it and very
strongly Josh mentioned safety have to
have safety but at the same time people
want this country open the people here
wanted open what date and there is a
danger to too much being confined to a
house or an apartment to wherever you
live you can't it just what we got to
start moving along and with all of the
testing we're doing with all of the
things we're doing you can do this now
and and governors are actually a lot of
pressures being put on governor's right
now by the people in their states they
want to get it open and that's what you
want that's what we all want and with
all of the procedures and safety we've
learned a lot about this hidden enemy
we've learned a lot and they'll be
pockets of fine I get that Paula it's
risky to give a date but I would rather
him just say listen the date will be
determined by how closely the country
helps me and adheres to the guidelines
like you could use this if if Trump were
a smarter politician if he were you know
a lot of her things he would take this
as an opportunity to say the dates not
up to me the date is up to the virus and
it's up to the people and the more
people stay home the more people were
masked the sooner the date is going to
be period programs that we set up their
businesses were gone one man he was a
chef like listen it with five children
and his mother lived with him and his
wife and he got lost the chef was living
with five people the question was what
is the date and I know it would be
responsible to just give a date but use
the question to help rather than to
dissemble pretty amazing display of what
we've done to help a lot of people and
you have millions of people like that
millions that have been helped where
they will have a job right now and where
the business of small business would
have closed now these are big businesses
but the small businesses would have
closed and I think it's great when when
win which is a terrific group of people
but when Matt says that you know we're
supporting all of the people I know what
that is that's a big you have all you
practically a full staff and you have no
income that's a big thing that's a great
thing and I hope you're rewarded for the
thank you thank you very much that's a
tremendous thing target date as as soon
as possible some states are already open
I mean they're opening up rapidly we
have a number of I'm opening up on
Monday we have a number of them opening
up sooner than that were partially
opening some of them even very even with
a very strong bent toward opening
they're opening up with a lope at a
certain amount here restaurants at 25%
then going to a 50% then ultimately we
want to be back to where the we're a
hundred percent we don't want we add one
restaurant don't to come up to me and
said sir you know I'm going to be there
opening up but if I distance too much I
have 50% of the restaurant I had I said
and you'll also have a worse atmosphere
we want to be back where we can have we
want it to be the way it was because the
way it was is the right way we can't
have somebody with a half a restaurant
do you understand again 175 seats now
he's got half we've got a president I
can't pay the rent I think you can get
by with half a lot of ways same thing
with an owner I was on the phone with
the commissioners and some of the owners
of sports of of big-time sports and
owners was talking almost like what he
was gonna have two or three seats in
between everybody that was there I said
no and I said you know you're not gonna
have to do that for that long you know
it's you're gonna be back he said really
oh really it was like he said certainly
get used to this because this virus is
going to be gone and when it's gone you
want to get back to Trump wants to be
able to look at sports again Stadium
that's 30% the size of what it was three
months ago
if I watch Alabama play LSU I don't want
to see 20,000 people instead of 120,000
people right we want it to be the way it
was now we've got to wait till it's gone
question is it will be gone and we've
done a lot to get rid of it
but we we want to open our country the
people want this country open
this 100% scenario you're laying over
one that's the way well yeah is that the
full vaccine or up to the vaccine so a
lot of progress is being made in a
vaccine but not no not the quite never
know you know with SARS they didn't come
up with a vaccine and sometimes they
don't and sometimes they do I will say
this I don't think there was the same
effort because a lot of people don't
know what's ours is the question is can
we get to a hundred percent before
there's a vaccine that's a very specific
question what's happened as an example
with Ebola with AIDS with others that
have been so incredibly successfully if
not eradicated these HIV is mostly
sexually transmitted the transmission of
Ebola is via bodily fluids I mean that
this is so stupid
mple that's far ahead of schedule so
we're looking for vaccines were looking
for therapeutics also I mean I think
therapeutics right now I'd rather if you
gave me both I'd rather have to serve
because that you know makes people
better right now no that's very dumb if
you look at the number of people
currently infected versus the number of
people who could be made immune with a
vaccine does everything he's saying is
idiotic having some good results one of
them was was Gilead today the full
restaurant theoretically Couponing no
I'm not relying on that I hope that's
gonna happen Johnson & Johnson Oxford a
lot of really first hand I think good
stories very promising but they have to
test it you know maybe it's not safe
maybe it eradicate sit but it's not safe
and you know they have to do testing
with vaccines where's the therapeutics
it's it goes a lot quicker in terms of
the process know if you don't have a
vaccine if the virus is gone we're like
we were before but having a vaccine
would be a great thing and I think we're
gonna get there in this case just based
on what I know but yeah we'll see what
happens look at some point to Gilead
research has been I mean that's gone so
fast that's gone at a level of speed
that nobody's ever seen before
and that's a stepping stone so I think
they're doing very well but no I want to
get I want to get back with or without
but oh you know obviously we have to
wait till it's gone
it'll be gone and we want to be back to
where we were yes without a vaccine sir
why do you think the virus will just be
gone there we go it's going to leave
it's gonna be gone what's gonna be
erratic okay pick it out guys and it
might take longer it might be in smaller
sections it'll be it won't be what we
had and and we also learned a lot again
if you have a flare-up in a certain area
if you have a I call them burning embers
boom we put it out we know this is why
they're shifting to talking about
economics because when it's economics we
all know it's [ __ ] but it's like
okay it's passable we're cleaning hotel
rooms what a big miracle Amazings gonna
thanks got this as soon as the question
becomes related to an element of medical
excuse the term it's off the rails in I
believe nine different plants that made
other products in some cases cars in
some places other things these companies
General Motors and and Ford in another
way and and GE so many companies have
Honeywell they've stepped up thorium has
been terrific they've stepped up like
nobody's ever seen before and he's
listing companies when the question had
nothing to do with that they're doing on
vaccines and Dohrn therapeutics has been
great too we'll see I mean we'll let you
know about that in a little while please
mr. president up today partially on
reports that the Treasury secretary and
other is made what is it up to depends
on pitch but it's but on the suggestion
that the Treasury secretary and others
may have presented you with a plan for
government assistance to the oil
companies well when our companies go and
get in trouble it's not their fault that
they got hit by fifty percent less
volume in one day bailing fake oil
companies to all of a sudden these very
great companies are employing all these
people so I'm talking to Steve and you
know what we just saved the airlines the
airlines were having the best year
they've ever had and then all of a
sudden they're like out of business we
can't let that happen so we have we
saved the airlines that's done we're
saving other companies and industries
and I would say Steve maybe you can talk
to it but I think the oil industry is
one of the top on the list so we're
looking at a lot of different strategies
we have a dedicated team combined of
people at Treasury and people at the
Department of Energy as I've said before
this is not gonna be a bailout of
shareholders but this is going to be
supporting the national security issue I
would just comment the Secretary of
Energy has done an extraordinary job of
taking in oil in the strategic reserve
and being paid for the storage capacity
in oil we're also exploring potentially
having the ability to store another
several hundred million barrels so we're
looking at lots of different options
were in touch with lots of people around
the world and the president is
determined that we I'll admit I'm
looking at getting a few barrels yeah I
mean at twenty bucks a barrel I might
throw in you know a couple hundred bucks
and just store some barrels a lot of
capacity meaning you can fill it up in
the national strategic reserves and you
know wasn't full and we made a great
deal if you would have told us that we
could have had that filled up or it's on
the way to being filled up at the kind
of pricing that we're talking about I
would have said you have to be kidding
we're talking about nineteen I'm not
sure Chris is gonna be
happy about this because it doesn't
pertain to the hotel business don't get
scared but you know we're talking about
like 1952 pricing it's pretty
unbelievable its prices that are so low
okay and in some cases with storing oil
and getting paid for storage because we
have a tremendous capacity for it so
what's happened shipping clerk but he'll
hold your oil for you you know it's this
week do you have a timeline say
additionally it might be announced this
week or do you have a timeline say it
for a while well it's evening a plan I
would say shortly I mean right now we're
dealing with some of the big ones but
where the big ones are very strong
they've been very strong over the years
I think that they're not going to have
the problem but we have a lot of great
people and a lot of great jobs in Texas
and Oklahoma and North Dakota and other
states that are great its energy it's
not I don't even call it oil I call it
energy this is this is the backbone of
the world really you know you can talk
all of the green I'm all for green but
the green can't power these massive
factories that are being built in this
country it just can't
the windmills aren't going to be able to
do it and solar is not gonna be able to
do it I love solar but it's not going to
be able to do it and you know we're
getting it for the right price but we're
not gonna let our that's we're not true
but it's also it's not obviously as
simple as just you I mean there's more
to this I've covered it before and
Trump's lying but it's just it's more
complex than this so we're working on
that very hard I think protecting energy
and energy independence to me that's a
very big part of what happened you know
we it energy has really helped to me
turn this country into the economic
power that it's been and we're not going
to let that go
I'm sure it's gonna have a couple of bad
years we have a tremendous oversupply
the reason we have the oversupply though
number one it was a very efficient
business and but the reason we have it
is because the demand got cut in half
one day by this
by this plague one day all of a sudden
take a look at the roads it goes from
packed highways everybody traveling
going all over to no cars on the road I
mean that was 25-30 percent right there
but then there's other things factories
that aren't working right now because of
this we did a great thing last night
using the powers that we have to make
sure that the processes and and all of
the delivery of our food chain that it
was protected and safe and those people
we were on the phone with all of them
this morning pretty much all of them as
you probably know they were cheering
literally cheering over the phone we did
some good moves not moves not money move
so much as as common sense folks because
they were being you know they were being
hurt by stupidity and a lot a lot of
people behaved like that work so I think
we put out that's called burning embers
too we put out a fire so there'll be
plenty of meat and pork and everything
that you want yeah and mr. president you
said you were anxious to get out the
White House might we see some travel in
the next week or so I think so I think
I'm going to Arizona next week and we
look forward to that and I'm going to I
hope oh hi oh very soon and we're going
to start to move around Oh hopefully in
the not too distant future we'll have
some massive rallies and people will be
sitting next to each other I can't
imagine a rally where you have every
fourth seat full every every six seats
are empty for every one that you have
full that wouldn't look too good no I
look I hope that we're going to be able
to do some good old-fashioned 25,000
person rallies where everyone's going a
while because they love our country that
to happen
well I'm going to Arizona and that's a
little bit different that's having to do
with industry because it's too soon for
you know for the big for the big
everybody get together and stand next to
each other crowds but that'll be next
week it'll depend it also depends on
States you know you have different
states some states are really in great
shape now and some states will be in
great shape yeah go to Montana and find
25,000 people don't want to come to one
of your rallies I mean it's pretty
incredible even if you look in New York
I spoke with Governor Cuomo at length
today and you know they were on that
other side of the curve a lot less it's
been hit very hard you know it's it's
New York and you probably would expect
that but there are the other side of
that curve the the bed usage and the
people coming to hospitals is way down
much lower than it was so a lot of very
positive signs are happening okay sir
presidency you have act to be able to
hold rallies before the election I hope
so
I hope so look we have a tremendous pent
up demand they love what we're doing and
they don't want to have taxes raised
they don't want to have stupid things
happening they like the trade deals
we've made great trade deals and OOP it
is the word of the day for Trump in this
country and that's what they want and we
have a lot of them that were lined up
and ready to be done right Kevin we have
deals that we're lined up with countries
ready to be done that was so good for
our country so good for our workers and
then this scourge came along and you
know that's the last thing people are
thinking about right now it's or we put
them on hold for a little while but but
now I hope to have I hope to see
football games and baseball games and
basketball know about basketball you're
gonna have to have a little bit of a
time I don't know what they're gonna do
maybe they'll be able to play sort of
toward the finals or the playoffs or
whatever they're doing
I told baseball is doing something very
unusual I don't know I don't know if I
agree with it I'd like to see the
Yankees played Yankee Stadium I see they
have some ideas for baseball that are
very different I guess I'm a
traditionalist but I think they'd be
able to play at Yankee Stadium with
obviously smaller crowds and then the
crowds would start to build as things
get to be a little bit better but you
imagine with what New York's going
through the idea that maybe in a month
Yankee Stadium would be open and I mean
is it this is crazy this is going away
think we're gonna come up with vaccines
and all but this is going away and when
it's gone we're gonna be doing a lot of
things and again you have to look other
areas there are areas you know we all
look at New York and we see New York and
New Jersey and some of these very high
density places where they're doing a
very good job it's just you know it's
not easy but you have areas that are
really at a very low point and and
really heading I always say heading
south quickly and that's what we want so
we'll see how it all works out I think
it's working very good how about one
more anyone else just on that point of
this going away not to belabor the point
but isn't it going away because people
are staying in their homes and people
are not traveling and once they go back
now
there's no evidence that it would go
away I cannot tell you how dedicated the
people of this country have been in
terms of that yeah you know one thing of
you staying home you're not catching it
if you stay in your place and you don't
go out and you know which is what people
were doing but they want to go out now
they want to get back and explain more
about that you stay home and you don't
catch it you say some of the facts are
coming out and we did all the right
moves that's how we did we wouldn't do
we're talking to Mike before if we
didn't do what we did you would have had
a million people die do you guys think
that that reacting when he says we were
talking to Mike do you think every day
he meets with pens and he goes Mike you
know we hadn't done what we did we just
we did all the right things Mike we
really did it you guys think that
conversation is actually happening every
day or to other countries but if you
really think about it
you could have had I take a look at
Elmer's hospital I take a look at some
of these places that I know growing up
in Queens and I know Elmhurst Hospital I
know these places very well like the
back of my hand and you see body bags
lying all over the hallways and outside
and going into refrigerated trucks and
multiply that number by 10 or 20 if we
didn't do what we did it wouldn't be
acceptable it wouldn't be sustainable
even though I would have access right it
would have been a terrible thing we've
just we've done it right I can't I can't
believe how incredible the American
people have been because they went out
and they really did this Chris you know
when you think they went out and and
they did what they had to do you know
there every once in a while a country
like Sweden will be thrown out or Brazil
oh no now Brazil is having a hard time
because they you know they they're
having a hard time well cuz their
presidents aluminium Sweden the people
in Sweden did it running around shaking
hands and hugging and kissing each other
you know they're the bars are closed or
the the people are staying in the house
the Prime Minister's don't have to
doesn't have to say in Sweden stay in
your house the people stay there
automatically and nobody using as an
example know what they've been hit hard
they've been hit hard but again they're
proud you call it automatic I mean it's
automatic distancing it's automatic
protection but places were closed the
bars were closed can't stand at the bars
you can't do certain things you know now
what we did was what we did is a great
tribute to this country but if we lost
so if we lose sixty five thousand people
it's so crazy to say that'll be Friday
dude but if we lose sixty-five thousand
people and instead of that going the
other route we would have lost a million
or a million and a half or two million
it's possible it's possible that you
lost more but could you imagine look how
horrible it is to lose sixty-five and
then multiply that times many many times
that would not be sustainable
so I think with all of that I want to
just thank everybody and I want to thank
these business folks are are just
tremendously talented people people have
no idea how talent that they are the job
they do and we're getting our way back
and we're getting our way back I think
much faster than people think and I
think it's going to be a much more a
much more successful launch and anybody
would have thought I really think next
year's going to be a tremendous year and
I think the fourth quarter is going to
be Larry I think the fourth quarter is
going to be fantastic I can feel it you
know I can feel the dimeric hello it's
going to be really fantastic thank you
very much everybody thank you so there
it is a very low energy downer Trump
today saying a lot of a lot of things I
don't know how I would characterize the
entire thing make sure if you've been
watching with me on YouTube and I so
appreciate if you have make sure to hit
that subscribe button on the way out I
hope you'll join me on future streams a
thanks to everybody who watched on
Twitch Twitter and Facebook many many
new clips coming up over the next
several hours thanks for joining me
you